hi my name is Don Swanson and I am the
writer and director of occurrence at
Mills Creek we're currently running an
IndieGoGo campaign to raise funds to
make a feature film based on a short
film which certainly isn't anything new
but our approach is kind of unique to it
and that our short film is in actuality
the opening act of the future film all
of this started back in 2016 I was
working on another project with a young
actress named Alexa mecklink and she was
being kind of hyper whatever and so I
joked with her that if she didn't settle
down I was going to write a script where
I slur through it and about a year and a
half later she asked me what was going
on with that idea and basically at the
time we'd come off of that feature had
done another short project and quite
honestly I was pretty tired and I was
just looking to do something kind of fun
on a weekend where you know we could do
some cool horror gore stuff and the idea
that I kind of came up with was what's
the worst fate that a daughter could
suffer and in my mind that would be
emotionally and physically and mentally
tormented and betrayed by her mother and
so that's where the slashing of the
throat came in and everything this idea
that a mom was messing with her daughter
kind of punishing her mentally and
emotionally before actually taking the
ultimate price of her life and I kind of
worked on the script and got it to a
pretty good point and some other people
became aware of it and that's how we
landed Betsy Linn George ultimately and
it was actually Betsy that suggested
maybe it's the sister because she saw
the mom as more of a caregiver and as it
kind of like took that direction all
these different threads started to grow
out of it and before long I had so much
kind of like backstory and possibilities
for these characters that it was well
beyond that base concept of a 10
it kind of like character
horror-thriller piece dealing with that
moment before the daughter's death and
we kind of took off based on the people
that were getting involved in everything
and we realized that there was so much
more to the story not just kind of like
bulking up that bit but that that was
just like a chunk of a story so kind of
like went and restructured that a little
bit to bring in a little more depth to
some of the characters that were
involved and these ideas of where it
could go what it could all possibly mean
so as the short kind of came into focus
it became apparent that it was more
psychological than horror and it was
more family drama and with that being
the case there was much more to tell
than just that little bit I have been
involved on crowdfunding projects before
more in like a supportive kind of role
this is the first time that I've been
the person responsible for an in charge
of it but in both of those instances we
had something to show one that I did
with a collaborator John Patrick
Driscoll in 2012 we had shot the short
we were seeking funds to complete it and
one that I helped out with Tom Williams
and Chris Lee we actually shot a very
professional and very structured concept
trailer using who is going to be our
telling everything and so from that
experience I learned that you want to
have something to show if at all
possible you know you don't just want to
get up there and be like hi I'm
so-and-so and I got a great idea and you
should give me money like we wanted to
actually show something and also to kind
of like see if it could potentially work
my initial plan was to let the short
play the festival circuit for about six
months or so to kind of build some buzz
some awareness and things like that and
then go into the crowdfunding but as it
kept progressing more and more people
found out about it more and more people
wanted to be involved with it
and basically we just kind of gotten to
a place where I it would work against us
to wait more so than it would help and
the way that it's structured is the last
scene of the short film is designed to
work in two ways
literally just two or three shots change
the entire scene one version ends the
short you know and it keeps it in that
idea of more exploring kind of like a
psychological illness and
disillusionment and the other one
springboards it to what could be one or
two years in the future and it picks up
again where the lead character Clara
played by Ava Soros is actually working
through the issues that she experiences
in the short so it's in that way it's
almost like a sequel to the short but
all told in one story and so the short
in and of itself explores these themes
it is a complete story you know it has
the beginning the middle the end and all
that kind of thing but it ends on a more
ambiguous kind of like gum challenging
you to think about reality kind of way
whereas by tweaking that last scene it
gives us a springboard to jump into the
future and basically see the effect that
all of us had on Clara and then it gives
us even more fun to kind of play around
with her in a psychological sense
because then we get to do all kinds of
things where what's real and what wasn't
real like what from the short actually
happened what from the short didn't
actually happen and her entire reality
gets to be blurred so whereas basically
the short is centered around this idea
of her dealing with guilt over the death
of her sister we take that and we just
like run wild with it in the future you
know like we begin to pick away her
reality were able to like give her a
life and then take it away from her
we're able to kind of like give some
kind of backstory some kind of a death
to her family because at the root of it
it really is about these three
and we're really able to get into those
notions of family and it's really cool
because we are concentrating on these
female characters specifically you know
and we're looking at kind of
mother-daughter relationships sister
relationships and things like that
and we're adding that kind of like
stress that kind of like family dynamic
which is dramatic by nature and we're
putting it in a horror blanket except
we're kind of like playing with it
psychologically so basically we set
Clara up in the short and then we just
knock her all over the place in the
feature and we take all these ideas and
we run with them further and you know we
kind of complete that story so we are
using the same footage we are using the
same actors I mean that was the plan
once we started actually rolling on the
short you know that this would be 1/4 of
the feature film where independent very
independent we are ultra low-budget
everybody who's working on this is
working on it because it's a passion
project of some sort we all believe in
what we're doing and ultimately we don't
have the luxury or the time to reshoot
anything really you know so I we were
able to basically structure the opening
act from the short film so yeah Ava
still Clara Betsey Lynn George is still
Emily
Alexa Michael is still Cassandra some
other actors who appeared in the shorter
also coming back for the future
including Jo official as Victor Emily's
husband and the girl's father i Linda
Maroney who worked with George Romero in
the 70s on the crazies and season of the
which is coming back as Anna stone along
with some others so yeah all of the same
actors all of the same footage you know
it is quite literally just like two or
three shots in the last scene of the
short that transitions the short is as
stands the opening to the feature with
those few changes so as I said before my
initial idea was to wait six months to a
year before going on with the feature
but we
so many amazing opportunities kind of
present themselves such as medicine Adi
and other cast members and just
opportunities so places to shoot an
interest that it would actually hurt us
to wait so the short film is being used
as our ability to show we're more than
just an idea you know we're doing this
we've done this we've started this and
that's probably from my personal
experience in crowdfunding the biggest
piece of advice that I could give any
filmmaker out there that's looking to do
it on any level but be more than just a
talking head saying we've got this great
idea you know like have something to
show even if you've got a like rack up
the credit card a little bit to put
together some kind of a concept trailer
with the talent you hope to use have
something to show so ultimately the way
it ended up playing out for us where we
are the short film for us is are
something to show it's our start it's
our ability to say we're doing this you
know it's not just an idea it's
something that actually is happening and
people can get a sense of what we're
about and what we're doing based off of
that and then decide you know for
themselves if they think we're worth
supporting or not which of course I hope
they do